après ta phut donc du collège là était
arrivé à paris alors qu'elle fait plein
de boulot comme tous les gens qui
débarquent à paris et ça c'est toujours
le côté dit que c'est toujours le côté
dickens qui continuent alors bon il a
été secrétaire tel était chauffeur de m
mais tu as été aussi livreur pour une
société de dessous féminins raconte de
vince été très très troublant gens et je
ne connaissais rien des choses et encore
moins des dessous féminins et je me
travaillait à travers paris pour aller
livrer des slips qui s'appelait volupté
ouais soir soir c'est pourquoi je me
suis donc baladé pendant un an à travers
paris et ans avec des combinaisons des
slips des soutiens gorge
et pendant ce temps c'était figurants
donc le soir à la comédie fera la
comédie française
on s'amuse les jeux les double jeu rick
le jeu et c'est vrai que je vais choisir
un pseudo qui était femme non non ça
c'est pas moi c'est ainsi le diagramme
fabrice de nolay c'est quand j'avais 12
ans doivent être faire du théâtre jean
un cahier de classe je faisais des
fausses affiches
alors je m'étais trouvé un nom de
terreur avec j'étais plus petit alors
que j'avais donc non je m'appelais
fabrics de claire regard ce serait
difficile à porter aujourd'hui tu
imagines à brive dimanche par brice de
claire voyageurs
ça commençait à marcher c'est le début
de la gloire éviter pas mal d'échecs en
faut bien le dire aussi
comme tout bon jeu final c'était quoi
parce qu'on parle toujours de na s'était
parole hold up à deux à l'heure 1 ça
n'est pas évident de faire rire avec un
sujet sur les gens âgés parce que les
gens ont peur des gens âgés sa terrorise
un peu les gens et puis je sais pas
c'était peut-être un peu naïve dans la
facture et je crois que bon ça n'a pas
été un succès loin de là ça m'a coûté ma
j'ai dû à rentrer à la télé pour payer
oui et ça t'a coûté aussi pas mal
d'années dans les supermarchés à faire
des signatures sinon c'était avant et
pour pouvoir faire le film j'ai fait des
signatures dans les supermarchés comme
on en fait tous à elle si tu n'en fais
pas un jour à perdre alors jamia tu as
bompas et enrichissant i la lune entre
les dents qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est la même question
ouais ça c'est je veux pas en parler
non je ne fais pas du mal comme ça en se
fixant les objectifs très très difficile
de vouloir faire plein de choses en même
temps et que j'arrive et je crois que
c'est le secret de la vie et du mal non
pas du tout il faut se fixer des
objectifs très haut très haut
et puis si on loupe attend pur commence
il ya pas de honte alors cassé la gueule
car finalement on aurait pu être curé
archevêque arche verts qui aurait pu
être chanteur d'opéra t'aurais pu être
journaliste aurait pu être écrivain
animateur télé
est ce que vraiment l'impression d'avoir
gâché un immense talent alors là je veux
bien en expliquer mais ce sera en tête à
tête si tu veux bien un le concernant
qui est maintenant mais le prends pas
mal ça suffit ok d'accord bon allez lens